la crainte et le stress supplémentaire
du personnel soignant
c'est de voir une affluence comme on a
vu dans les autres pays
brutal des des malades est là et on
stresse pour la disponibilité du des
équipements de protection surtout nous
qui manipulant les voies aériennes des
passions donc le risque de contamination
est vraiment accru il ya une influence
des sujets jeunes ces derniers temps
c'est pour ça que nous on vraiment on
essaie de sensibiliser au maximum la
population
on le redit tout le monde est concerné
par le confirmant on parle par le
confinement pardon jeunes sujets jeunes
sujets âgés et tout le monde est
concerné par les mesures de prévention